so it tells the story of those European
artists who had to flee Paris because of
political upheaval and made their home
in London so it feels like an extremely
important story to be telling about how
and the how British art was shaped and
by European influences our propel a new
tradition as Judaism circular case I'm a
part of a German photonics the
exposition who told this artist raschel
Atari in a satanic universe' Liepaja
geneticist are a local college
the paintings that were made in that
period in very many ways shaped how we
think about London some of the most
romantic views of the Thames and
Westminster you know the great houses of
parliament and were done by French
painters in particular by Monet and they
have had influence down the years but
also it was tremendously exciting for us
to to gather a range of paintings which
hadn't been seen in the UK for a very
long time and since the exhibition is
also exploring cross channel exchanges
and collaborations and it felt like a
really important thing to be doing at
the moment and I tend to do leagues in
the desert at hospitals exhibit his
cough or say if I'm a novice moan
electricity a book would succeed a
tragedy complete these artists keep a
vet yah-yah-yah theory of home comma
comma Romanova doctor postcode
experience first presently Don is Peter
they could Dakota
well I think each institution presents
an exhibition in their own unique way so
for me it's very exciting to see how the
Pucci Palais has addressed the whole
concept of the exhibition who made it
fit for their spaces but I'm also very
keen to see how French visitors respond
to if you like their artists presenting
London back to them so there's a kind of
back and forth going on in the
exhibition that I think will be
immensely rewarding for visitors
an Afghan is a the bridge sections the
Dickinson body you see the dispositive
attractive who started exposition in the
tab interact each new CD Bonneville
yellow suit ah ha dong kyun par look at
our loop additional this is potassium
you may see the melodic or shaded
position Patel ammonia to really geek
what we gain from these kinds of
collaborations is is both - sharing of
curatorial knowledge often scholarly
research is exchanged across the
institutions it also allows us of course
to share the exhibitions with a much
wider audience but I think the each the
two institutions working together are
able to forge something that they
wouldn't be able to do on their own
incredible - are you men now Connie
Sarah what large is a short the tableau
the hodr composite affair the members of
City Star artistic if I'm a technology
part most Muslim appropriately men
police he keeps the dream easy the
boudoir beautiful tale of a lager so
these artists
there is one that particularly resonated
with me because I think it has a rather
London melancholia to it it's the
portrait by Monet of his his wife
Camille
it's called meditation she's sitting
back on a sofa and she looks rather
mournful I have to say and there's a
sense of arrival in England and she had
only recently married when she she came
to to join her husband who was in exile
and you get a sense of the unfamiliarity
of Amelia for her and I'm afraid to say
she looks rather so forth but it means
it's a very powerful and emotional
painting her ability to present to cool
vaseline or d'Elegance that extra
misogyny in kusu-kusu complex telepathic
communications santa extra no Saddam the
killer - Antipas who are normal elegant
looking of the booty saw so we see the
priests accumulate the baton it mentions
is the chronology the rest in Busan